Islamic pilgrimage to Mecca is compulsory for all Muslims in good health...
...and with sufficient funds to make the journey.
The hajj is the foremost of all Muslim rituals...
...even if less than ten percent of all Muslims ever manage to complete it.
The hajj's importance lies in its allowing the believer...
...to approach the center of the world,...
...as well as the place where the Koran's divine revelations began...
...and continued for about 12 years.
The performer of hajj does not only reenact Muhammad's ritual.
He or she also recalls acts of important people in Muslim history.
The rituals performed around the Kaaba reenacts when prophet Abraham and Ishmael...
...transformed the Kaaba into the sacred place of worship and peace.
In spite of some physical hardships, pilgrims who complete the hajj...
...consider it one of the greatest spiritual experiences of their lives.
Many Muslims regard the hajj as one of the great achievements of civilization...
...because it brings together people from around the world...
...and focuses them upon a single goal.
A believer is required to make the pilgrimage at least once in his or her lifetime.